[Music]  I'll start at the beginning my whole  family was killed in a car accident  someone did horrific experiments on me I  was abducted raped and forced to kill  someone and I'm in here so how was anger  management still angry some people call  me a hero others call me a freak you're  one of them [ __ ]  I didn't ask for this I'm just trying to  make it goddamn living in this goddamn  city your pie  I'm resourceful people I care about are  in danger I got to make a decision one  keep denying it or to do something about  it we belong way down below  I don't know honey way in the world it's  called a whiskey  [ __ ] call me a [ __ ] again Jessica  Jones  you are a hard-drinking  short fuse mess  anything dad  Miss Jones yeah I always see what  threats head-on meaning I punched them  in the head until they're unconscious  [Music]  [Music]